los aliados han reafirmado que Ucrania
se convertirá en miembro de la otan ni
han dejado Claro que invitarán al país a
ser miembro de la alianza Pero siempre y
cuando se cumplan una serie de
condiciones para empezar cuando haya
acabado la guerra pero segundo cuando se
hagan las reformas necesarias internas
dentro del país Como por ejemplo la
lucha contra la corrupción además se ha
reafirmado el compromiso de que se
acelerará el proceso de entrada a
Ucrania en lugar de los dos pasos que
suelen ser habituales se va a pasar a
uno para que así cuando Ucrania esté
preparada se pueda producir esta
adhesión lo antes posible los líderes
también han apoyado un plan financiero y
también militar para que las puertas
armadas del país de Ucrania estén lo
máximo preparadas dentro de los
estándares de la otan cuando se produzca
el momento de la adhesión la cuestión es
si lo acordado hoy entre los líderes
aliados va a convencer a Ucrania el
presidente ucraniano budímir ha sido muy
crítico en sus redes sociales porque
cree que si no hay una fecha exacta un
calendario claro de cuándo va a entrar
Ucrania dentro de la alianza esto da
alas a Moscú a seguir agrediendo al país
el comunicado ha sido uno de los más
complicados a negociar aseguran Fuentes
aliadas también las mismas Fuentes
aseguran que nunca antes había dado a un
país que no forma parte de la
organización tantas garantías para que
pueda entrar en el futuro dentro de la
alianza a pesar de que no haya un
calendario fijo la alianza con este
mensaje da un apoyo claro inequívoco a
Ucrania por y como prueba de ello Es por
ejemplo el consejo entre Ucrania y la
otan que se celebra mañana